So in the previous section, Phillip
explained why
the problem of multiple pattern matching
is important.
And he further gave an algorithm
for solving the multiple pattern matching
problem.
But let's see, what is the way in which he
solved the problem?
Here is the genome as the road, and here
is the pattern as a student.
So basically what Phillip does, is he
asked the student to go
along the road and find all the matches
that a
pattern can match.
But please remember that
we have multiple patterns.
So this approach force us
to slide the patterns along the genome
multiple times.
OK?
Here we slide.
This approach takes a lot of time.
The time complexity of this algorithm
is O( |genome size| * |Patterns| ).
In brute force, the combined length of all
the patterns, is huge.
And this, algorithm is not that practical.
Now, I'm describing another approach, so
instead of asking
individual patterns to go along the
genome, one at a time
I pack all of the patterns into a single
structure and move this structure along
the genome only once.
So, it is similar to packing all the
students onto a bus
and move the bus just one on the road.
This data structure has a very important
property.
It can retrieve the pattern very quickly.
Like, if a father here asks if Taca is on
this bus?
The bus driver can say "I can retrieve
Taca" very quickly.
So, this data structure is called a
Trie, coming from the word retrieval.
So the Trie is a data structure for
representing a collection of patterns.
And the tries support fast pattern
matching.
Now, given us a set of patterns, the
idea is to combine all these patterns into
a rooted tree, with branches labeled by
letters in the alphabet.
And every string in the patterns
correspond to a path from the root to a leaf.
Let's go through this example with me, to
understand how we can construct a trie
from a collection of patterns.
OK?
We start with a root and the first pattern
is banana.
So from the root the first character of
banana is b.
There is no b here so we have to create a
new branch and label it my b.
The next character is a.
So we have to create a new branch and
label it by a, and so on, so fourth.
An a.
So for the next pattern, p-a-n.
We start from the root, there's no p.
So we have to create a new branch p here,
OK?
And a, n.
The next one is "and".
We start from the root, there's no "and"
going down from the root, so we have to
create one, 'a' and the next one is n-d.
Next one is n-a-b, "nab".
We start from the root.
We don't have 'n' so we have to create a new
one and a-b.
OK?
Antenna, we start from the root.
But please note that' a' here we have a
branch
labelled by 'a', so we don't have to
create new one.
We just follow it down.
Go to next 'n', here the next one is 't'.
We don't have' t', so we have to create a
new one.
And e-n-n-a.
The next one is bandana.
We start from the root.
We have b already,
so we don't have to create a new one.
So, a-n, there's no d going
down, so we have to create a new one.
And a.
Next one is ananas.
We, we have a already, so we just follow
down.
And here 'a', we don't have 'a', we have to
create a new 'a'.
OK?
n-a-s.
The next one is nana.
We start from the root.
"nana": we go through a n-a, there
is no 'n' next, so we have to create a new
one, here right.
OK?
So this tree, this rooted tree is called a
trie, constructed from a set of patterns.
So a trie is a
rooted tree with branches labelled by
letters in the alphabet.
Every pattern is a path
from the root to the leaf.
For example, banana.
It correspond to path from the root to the
leaf.
But please note that in this example, we
have some errors here.
If you want to construct a trie for
yourself, you need
to add a new characters dollar at the end
of each pattern.
(Denoting an end of a word in the trie.)
We don't have space so allow us to have
some mistake here.
So, the question now is, how to use the
trie for pattern matching?
Before, Phillip had to move individual
pattern, one
at a time, along genome, to find a match.
Now, we have already created a special
structure called a
trie that packes all the patterns into a
single data structure.
Now the ultimate thing we have to do
is to move this data structure along the
genome.
OK.
Here we have the string, that's the
genome, panamabananas.
The trie, constructed from the set
of patterns we want to match.
First we put the trie at the first
position of the string.
P, and we want to ask a question,
whether there is any pattern in this
connection
that can match at this position on the
genome.
So we just swap down from the root nearest
p, so this is a p-match.
We walk down a-n.
So good.
So at this position we can find a match:
"pan".
We move the trie to the next position,
so, and we try to walk
down the tree from the root to the leaf of
the tree, to find if there is any match.
So, we could find 'a' here, next one is 'n'.
Next one is 'a' here, yes we can find.
Next one is 'm'.
No.
In the trie, we don't have anything.
Going out from this we don't have label 'm'
so at this position we cannot find any match.
We move the trie, one more time.
An n here a-n we cannot find n, so that is
no match at this position.
We move to the next.
We start with a-n, here we got stuck we
cannot match so we have to move.
We can say that at this position there is
no path
that matches.
This position immediately there is no
match.
Next position 'a' here, there is no match
here,
we move to the next b-a-n-a-n-a-s.
OK, so we can find a match here.
So we move it to the next one,
a-n-a-n-a-s.
Exactly.
So we can find a match at this position.
So next one is n-a-n-a.
We can find a match.
So we move next, a-n-a-s.
There is no 's', so walking down.
So at this position we cannot find any
path that matches.
Similarly, we move the trie,
here we cannot find any match, here we
cannot find match, here, immediately we
cannot match.
OK?
So, to recap.
In this section I have described a data
structure called a trie.
Which is a representation of a collection
of strings.
This data structure allows us to retrieve
a pattern from
the collection very quickly.
And the run time of the trie-matching, now
we have reduced it to the genome
multiplied by the longest pattern.
Where in the previous algorithm that
Phillip described,
it takes genome multiplied by
the total length of all the patterns.